[Music]
and million dollar heist news okay
million dollar Millie that's it money
submitted by mr. pickle
there's a sandwich shop called uh-huh
where are you from Sacramento [ __ ] the
buggy but it's so [ __ ] California you
make it sound like you're from like the
East Coast and [ __ ] you don't have it
out here oh you know I won today aren't
you she's on one that I did well we're
getting fight this [ __ ] looks out a
cute today
loving all the [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] let's
continue youtuber and beauty girl
jeffree star says his makeup warehouse
was broken into with millions in product
stolen who's Jeffrey's target familiar
he's huge he was famous and like MySpace
days remember like the pink pink hair
like the serial a guy make sure he was
like you've seen it I'm sure you see you
know he would go viral all the time on
MySpace yeah dude I Brown a white guy
hold on okay I pulled it up look at him
Smith that is not what I don't know I
have never seen him once in my life you
have you have this exact picture but
like the person okay is he he's pretty
revolutionary yes I browser normally he
doesn't make up this stuff that he is he
a transgender I don't think he
identifies as anything yeah yeah I don't
think he I think he's still just a
unicorn so shouldn't we force him to
identify as something no there's some
people that are fluid or they just don't
want to both identify don't have to
force him to identify his fluid then I
don't know Jeffery starts everyone to
identify something that's the Trump said
dude he has so much money he's just a
free start yeah literally
entrepreneur like he had no money and
they keep like created this makeup
branding he's just [ __ ] huge now
because he had like music and stuff I
mean had music what he never took it
anywhere like it was kind of wack how
rich are we talking about like Sheila's
like Calabasas Nokia Kyle he lost
millions in just inventory just
inventory you know what
once you're that risk you don't have a
dick or [ __ ] dude that sounds like he
does octet
just something else you're just royalty
yeah you're something out there it was
just straight like a [ __ ] a king queen
or something a queen
he's just Jeffrey started literally team
Queen a jacket ace yeah I identify as a
peasant go ahead right now what was it
anyway
it came out of my mouth cleaning it I'm
a Native American I don't let food waste
five-second rule
that's my bad y'all oh you uses every
part of the egg white alright so Jeffrey
star has revealed that his warehouse got
broken into and he lost about 2.2
[Laughter]
million dollars that's a lot of money
and the shadiest part of this whole
thing he's he thinks that it was an
inside job it always is because the
people who stole like they knew exactly
where to go for and he has this new line
that he hasn't even launched yet it was
new product yeah a concealer well yeah
you know everything sure that's my shape
I want three orders all day this is
three broken through the roof
Oh what that's time and then be like
ransacked his warehouse and they didn't
even discover the the fact that they
stole like a whole bunch of one shade of
them you can I like the comic book font
they used to show the alleged break-in
spot TMZ thought oh my god what makes
them think it's an inside job oh because
of the fact that they were so they broke
into like a refrigerated area
where they keep makeup like at a certain
temperature yeah so he hasn't released
that concealer yet like how she
mentioned yeah and they stole the
majority of like just one shade oh why
is that like the most popular shade I
don't know maybe they [ __ ] up it
sounds like the it sounds like they
stall like their next super secret lunch
yeah that's exactly what the motivation
is like how would anyone even know about
the super super lunch yes because he had
trademark like designs for what the
concealer would actually look like like
the product design so people were trying
to like look into like what is this new
line that he's coming out with or like
the new product because he had never
done like face she's never yeah he only
has like eyeshadow and lipstick listen
like highly responsive Bing is called
blue blood and blue blood and so he's
been waiting cuz this happened a few
weeks ago and he's been talking to the
FBI in police and he he hired a private
investigator to scour the internet to
see if anyone's trying to sell the stuff
go to Santee alley I guarantee it's
right there yeah so then it popped up on
Facebook when he's meeting with the FBI
does you have that pink wig on yeah yeah
well that's not his hair but he has pink
hair like up to here or does he like
dress a little bit more like Polly see
here's somewhere make up your sister own
track suits
he has like his own clothing line oh
sure yeah he's a businessman 15 ooh
sounds like a pin yeah this popped up on
Facebook in the knee and then this photo
popped up too and so it's someone
actually holding the concealer he he had
never released to the club so people
thought that this was fake and so I
started spreading online and so he
contacted some people asking I can you
please take it down because I have I
haven't even shown what is the product
yet and so they were able to track so
the this person that posted it on
Facebook she said that she took this
photo from someone else and from that
original person that person is now in
jail cuz they had like the product yeah
the product and then now this girl she
posted like an apology
apparently saying like oh I'm sorry
whatever the [ __ ] was she knew what she
was doing
I don't know if she's gonna be going to
jail too but yeah selling stolen
products is obviously very illegal right
and so she was saying that she was gonna
be selling it from that other girl that
is now in jail that's why I keep my
businesses small job yeah so you don't
want to be like 50 t-shirts that is
exactly why and you know French money
keep it small keep it tight try to steal
23 socks I don't think they understand
how selling things on the low works you
don't put it on Facebook that works
I think apparently it was like on the
black makeup market I didn't even know
that was a thing but black makeup yeah
like the black makeup market because it
might make counterfeit yeah I bet it's
on Etsy because every time on I'm on
Etsy looking for anything there's like
fake Alvie fake Gucci oh yeah yeah I'm
like how does Etsy get away with this
some Chinese lady do this oh yeah yeah
so this made headlines all over the
place har people are reacting to it are
they saying how do you hear about this
[ __ ] well it's not your world like if
they spell from Gorn and Ramsay like his
top [ __ ] you know I would I would [ __ ]
you would know oh I love corn and Ramsay
in general dude that [ __ ] scrotum
face think I know more about Fighters
injuries that I know about this oh for
sure that makes sense what happened I
don't know it's not like you had like a
burps Duggers away I don't trust office
nice you did date but actor prediction
nice I heard it yeah you're saying you
only know I know more about fighters
injuries I think than I do about the
makeup world well that's good baby about
the makeup or like like sending death
threats to like like that girl and stuff
like they're getting really serious
because I think any big influencer like
that people are like huge as
[ __ ] fans like getting tattoos
of their logos like it's yeah it's
insane people barber brigade
tattoos really yeah
humbly I mean that's a cool message but
on you I know I'm not that passion we
have I've seen people show up or like
tag me and pictures they tatted the old
logo yeah yeah it feels pretty crazy
because like when you make something
like you just make something that
yourself in your ears that your vibe
with you know what you kind of want to
put this message through a certain
artistic expression out there right and
it's pretty insane for people to like I
[ __ ] I'll put that in my skin oh [ __ ]
I can't believe somebody tattooed that
old just kidding films look someone did
that oh yeah you are so [ __ ] dumb
dude what's up I see some worst tattoos
dude I saw the art world whoever did it
did a great job but what I'm saying is
idiot anymore it's not we don't publicly
use they put it out there but at least
it's still there on the mug I Lisa
Stover it's where you could barely see
it's on that metal plate yeah either way
though I'm kidding though that's pretty
cool I mean I think anybody who just
feels that passionate about anything
it's kind of cool that you're like [ __ ]
it I'll [ __ ] stamp this on my body
you know yeah I'm sure we have worst
tattoos no mine are perfect wow this
beat because you got the one you were
like older you thought about it oh no
like know what I mean it's like I start
getting tattoos I was like sixteen that
[ __ ] was dumb as [ __ ] you know what I
mean which one did you get when you're
16 the ones on your arms no I got it
right here and got it and I got it
removed what was it it was just like a
bra so basically like I had this best
friend in high school and like Oh
backstabbing [ __ ] right it's already
going bad and like we're like let's get
this this guy in math class he was like
I'm doing tattoos on my house and we're
like [ __ ]
we went to his house and we're like well
we hold hands it'll be one heart do put
a [ __ ] ever and don't get that fight
that's [ __ ] though no stupidest [ __ ]
I hate that [ __ ] now
what Adam because you have half heart
that's broke it up so you're good
should've kept it well I mean this set
to stop me from getting a job in a now
so I was hella salty yeah cuz it was
like you know in and out people in now
pays well dude at ten I ended up working
out borders because of that but yeah I
got a removed it's just one dot now and
it hurt a lot so that's why I say wait
so when did you get your next tattoo
after that when I was 18 and I got it
this I have a whole video on this
literally but it was this one on my side
and like that was really bad too because
I didn't have money to get tattoo so I
just want to build waka another garage
it was at a house the dude he was high
as [ __ ] like it was bad I'm telling
y'all like you need to win
I was rough times girl my parents
weren't around it was just rough so okay
they should got mad dawg anyway yeah so
definitely wait but I don't think the
jakey's does badass like other tattoos
yeah not as bedroom bring you back in